I I just believe the best person for the
job should get the job and that's quite
radical at this moment in
time what I'm saying is underqualified
women shouldn't be shouldn't be in there
cuz they're taking qualified men's jobs
but we're sending the wrong message I
think we're sending the message of be
lazy be controversial be a victim cancel
people be a victim the the joke you made
about Fred and rosemary West see I knew
I knew it was going to have that
response because they're so fragile
these people as uncomfortable as it is
you have to be able to speak the truth
to power Joey welcome to the show you
are pissing more people off than even we
are which is an
achievement so welcome to the show uh
you you've been you've been talking a
lot uh and we wanted to have you on to
talk about uh you know your life and
where you come from and stuff you've
been through but also the stuff you're
talking about now you as I say you are
uh kind of upsetting triggering you
might say a lot of people because you've
dared to point out that some female
football pundits uh and not perhaps they
on Merit is that fair to say yeah yeah
absolutely yeah and and I I just believe
the best person for the job should get
the job um and that's quite radical at
this moment in
time um yeah I I just think we send the
wrong message you know
certainly if we're if if we're putting
people in position not because of the
skills and and the attitude and you
know the their ability then I just think
we send a dangerous message uh going
forward and look at societies only 41
but it's changed a hell of a lot in a
short space of time and I don't think
it's changed for the better because of
you know kind of Di and inclusion I'm
all for it I think when to look into
sports teams you know any team I've
being a part of the more varied the
better but it is unpend on on Merit you
know we need the best right back for the
team you know we need the best left
midfielder for the team to make the team
function not you know quot quoters and
and and boxers to tick and you know
sport is is the ultimate meritocracy
isn't it m you know know the the doping
and the financial doping and all the
other stuff that goes on off off the
pitch but on the pitch sport is you know
certainly football is is a is a true
meritocracy I think that's why people
love sport because at least they have
the idea that this is like one of the
few places in life where you're either
good or you're not you're either
performing or you're not uh and I'm
curious because you must have know
that saying what you're saying is going
to get is going to make difficult for
you to work in football let's be honest
yeah yeah is that fair to say well I
knew I was been in the boats yeah so
it's you know that was and and why have
you decided to speak up I mean let's be
honest you've always been a bit of a
troublemaker one absolutely yeah um why
I didn't decide to speak out it just
kind of came out
um I I I got sacked the Bristol Rovers
um we were taken over by a couple of
Kuwaiti investors quite different
principles culture just not
aligned principally with with the way I
see the world you know tried divide and
conquer strategy relatively early and at
that point I'm like okay this is uh this
is not for me I'm away from me family
I've been down at bristle 2 and a half
years to CH change the club's uh culture
and then coming out at the management
space and knew with this women's
commentating in football issue I knew it
was frustrating A A lot of people
certainly when I'm watching like because
I'm I'm listening to the the technical
nuances and knowing how incorrect they
are like I watch the game at the weekend
I I shouldn't
um um keep banging on about it but I
watch a game at the weekend the everon
game and I'm on the dodgy box you know
so I can watch all the streams from all
different countries to any way you know
you can get any way you can get football
you know live football at 3:00 on a
Saturday afternoon you can't get in our
country and yet all the other countries
got on so I'm watching ever Lon cuz for
me SS I'm an evertonian in the FA Cup
and the first the first goal that Luton
score is a foul it's just just if you
know what you're looking at it's it's a
foul so they get the go you've got the
male commentator and the female co-
commentator I believe the co-
commentators role has to be expert I
think they have to have spent a long
time either playing the game or time
saved in the game to give that Nuance
the the expertise to to the audience you
know if I'm a young kid out they
listening I want I want to I want to
know what's happening so I can apply
that to my game and they miss it and
they get it wrong and then the the male
the female ccoms is talking about
something else entirely she gets a goal
scor it
wrong when they show multiple rep plays
then you then see Ross Barkley push
Calvin lean in the back blatantly and
and it that little nudge is the
difference between Domino heading the
ball in the in the front post or
no after about the fourth or fifth
replay where she should be now saying
look V AR should should intervene
and uh dis low this goal she then says
oh it's really clever I'm I'm just
furiat watching the like God and I'm not
that I'm not a mad football fan anymore
because I played the game once you play
the game being a a died in the wolf fan
goals because you're a mercenary you're
a gone for higher you know I've played
against everon as a Newcastle player Man
City player and we' scored goals and
I've celebrated them and I've been
desperate to beat them so I can't no
longer claim to be a true aonian because
I don't want everon to above anything
else um
and for me the difficulty lies in if I
was watching the golf I'm a keing golfer
or the UFC or the boxing and the person
who was in the ccoms role or the pundit
role was given the wrong information
then that would that would give me
nonsense I wouldn't be getting that you
know stuff I applied to me game or stuff
I could really interpret and use in me
in me in in me boxing career whatever or
M MMA
career and the fact that this is going
on on every single media platform and
it's going on unchecked because people
are either listening to people make
mistakes and fearful of pulling them up
on it for the repa Sals or giving you
know we've seen a few guys I think in
seen Jensen button doing a few times in
the formula ones where where he looks at
the I think it's Dan Stewart or Patrick
is it and he's just like she's talking
about something to do with the driving
and you can see he's just like what the
[__]
you what is czecho supposed to do he
couldn't just lift off before the corner
and pull in behind cuz looking at that
there were cars there so they would have
had the opportunity to dive down the
outside of him and caused Mayhem you
know so it's a tricky one but it's when
you get to that point of deciding I got
to turn in now but I need to give them
room maybe I'll just run off track a bit
and come back on I think he should have
I think he should have lifted and pulled
in and been next to Carlos and been 2 by
two and just it's still a good start the
problem is lifting as well it causes
accidents so you can't just suddenly
lift because in an F1 car when you lift
there's so much drag that it does slow
you down very quickly and the the guys
behind get affected by that and it just
just fun it goes all the way back driv
one so fair you know he's obviously been
an elite level driver and and it's just
like and I think we want to see a
decreasing misogyny a decreasing racism
a decreas in sexism and and that is the
whole purpose of di you know bringing
down these barriers but when they force
it on you and and they force it on you
and and it's poor quality poor
journalistic standards then you get a
rise in Everton it was meant to defeat
in so it becomes it just becomes OBS
said I I agree with you it's a good
point Joey I think what I would say and
as someone who is a football fan when
you listen to the ccoms well and even
people who played at the elite level
frequently the standard is pretty crap
as well do you know what I mean yeah the
males like I'm I'm watching lots of mail
you know this has ended up being a bit
of a of of a volcano because if you
can't say anything now about certain
groups or people who've put themselves
in certain groups there's a lot of poor
male commentators out there really poor
cooms pundit as well the problem with
them guys is they've actually got Equity
they've got credibility they've played
the game and as stupid as their opinions
can be they're doing it from a from a
knowledgeable position I've
experienced uh you know the intensity or
the speed at which the game moves at or
the physicality or they've experienced
it and again you know good bad and
indifferent in in all the problem I have
with the women ex players is they have
no experience of it you know in in
essence it's pretty much a different
sport I know they'll argue same rules
into the same sport I'm like you know we
have to accept that women's cricket and
men's Cricket ain't the same you know
same with rugby women's rugby and men's
rugby now I prefer if I watched the
tennis I prefer to watch the women's
tennis firstly the better looking than
the men
secondly the the the rallies last longer
you know the men's game's pretty much
power save Ace bang you know I prefer
the women's golf sometimes to the male
golf because they hit the ball so if
they're playing a course I've played
they hit some of the shots that I can
hit the men don't they just hit it like
a 100 yards further so I can't relate to
it you know so when I watch women's I'm
not against women's sports I think
women's football has done fantastic in
our country you know I've never seen
more of it on TV you know there you know
the seen Trafalga Square I couldn't get
into trala square for the lioness's
final so it's
great but men and women's football like
if if I as a ex player I watch women's
football trying to be as kind as I can
to it but it's just not very good I look
I I agree with you compared to men's
yeah compared to men's you look at like
the elite level champions league for
instance the women's game no no in the
women's game it's nowhere near close
when you get to that Elite level of male
game they they they just can't compete
the reason that I find you funny on
Twitter Joey is you do like being
provocative mate you do like making a
joke and it is funny seeing people have
a meltdown for instance the uh the the
joke you made about um Fred and rosemary
West yeah that
is see I knew I knew it was going to
have that response because the
so they're so fragile these people like
like I don't know whether this is a
blessing or a case I've had that much
abuse in football stadiums and you can
imagine the Articles written about me in
the commentaries and people passing
comment on stuff of don't or said that
you just develop a bit of a thicker skin
yeah you know and when you've had as
much said to me as as what I have in the
end you realize it's it's me who's
taking offense to it yeah you actually
can't offend me you know it's not
possible for you to offend me I have to
at some level let you in to to be
offended so me and I used to work on
this thing of visualizing and the only
time I done Constantin the only time i'
done the Vim off breathing every single
morning was in the ban Le promotion the
year we won the league I religiously
used to get up and do it every morning
I've never felt clearer you know that
was a great weing environment that the
the manager built there and for me in in
terms of um you know provoking people
Blacky we would talk about stepping into
this like like almost like a you know a
bubble of strength and no one we're not
going to let anyone in the opposition
players the opposition fans the referee
we're not and if we choose to open the
door and interact with it then but we
know what so I as to worked on this kind
of visualization concept that didn't get
sent off that year lowest number of book
team of the year so there was a few
factors Vim Hof and and some of the
stuff just for people we were talking
before about Wim Hof breathing and your
Mentor is a
mentor who made a big difference in your
career in life In terms of I didn't move
that concept further out in terms of
like words and offense and you
know I I've I've used it I think to
benefit my life because you know you can
be offended every time you open the cens
if you want to be you know I find it
bizarre that people follow me on Twitter
or X as it's now called and get offended
at what I'm putting out there when no
one asked you to be here no now I also
now have worked out because I've been in
Twitter a long period of time although I
haven't used it but I've always kind of
monitored what's going on and I do think
it's got nuts oh Lots but if you use it
for what it is a tool you can you can
use it for benefit as as we clearly have
um and I just figured out I can't be I
can't why am I taking offense to that
just just block it out it's the same way
if I came in here and I would called you
a fat bastard you'd be like well I'm not
fat so you wouldn't get offended by it
you only get offended if there's an
element of Truth in it or the more Clos
to the truth it is the more it clearly
offends or triggers people as we want to
call it and you know I'm I've just got
to the point where I'm actually you know
I'm not trying to cause anyone any
offense like purposely want to make
people upset or unhappy but if me just
saying like basic truth is going to
trigger you to make it unhappy then [__]
you you know you know what's interesting
is like I'm actually not that big a
football fan the boys here at the studio
much more so than than but when I watch
some of the stuff that you're saying and
then I look at the stuff you're talking
about
it's hard to argue with what you're
saying and when I talk to people who are
not in the media space just normal
people I'm look people can agree or
disagree with your opinion about female
pundits but most people in the country
actually do share that opinion men and
women by the way they they they just do
yeah and and again I see the feedback I
have never had positivity or feedback
positively on on the stuff I've talked
about over the years
as much as as this so this is clearly
hit and N the fact that was still it was
a month about a month ago I tweeted
about you know let's be serious here the
women shouldn't have any Authority in
the men's game
like and and I'll I'm prepared to sit in
front of any exom player anyone want to
have a chat about but yet they just keep
attacking the messenger not the message
um and even Emma haes I went to the Le
in sport conference Emma spoke there
she's seen as the best woman manager in
the WSL you know she could be the
crossover I know there was a a lady who
stood in last night in the Bundesliga
for Union bailin and they won one- nil
cuz the manager got suspended for I
think pushing Leroy San in the face so
you got a three game five game eight
game ban something like that and a lady
his assistant manager is a lady she
stepped into one one so obviously you
know they can manage in the women's I'm
not saying they can't the women can
manage in the men's game I'm not I think
playing in the men's game really hell of
a lot harder for them but men going the
other way which is inevitable if they if
they don't um if they don't change the
law cuz only need 12mth cool off period
I looked into it cuz I thought I might
just [__] poke the
Box entirely you know I'm fairly fairly
overweight now for for what I was when I
played I'm 41 but I still think I could
be aing harand next season in the WSL
with the even if I have testosterone um
suppressors no danger I'm just bigger
stronger
faster you know they would wouldn't be
able to deal with that but then also
that the brain you know the little
nudges the new the dark arts the the
stuff that um you know would be very
very easy for me to apply in in the WSL
and be very very successful and then
they would be [__] wouldn't they
because they couldn't attack me if I
woke up and I said I'm Josephine Barton
and I'm playing in WL next year well now
they've got a they can't write negative
articles about me yeah you
know you know it's a good move in many
ways it is it is but then when you run
by your kids I'm like should I just piss
these off completely and they're like
life Dad don't we you know this the last
thing we need so if I didn't have kids I
would I would I would be tempted just to
poke the Box almost to say look this is
how absurd your position is but then you
know you don't want to make fun of what
is a serious topic you know serious
conversation and I'm just seeing now um
obviously the swimmer in in America is
trying to get in the
Olympics Thomas and then you've had um
obviously the woman golfer uh the the
man golf will win the women's golf um
we've covered this issue a fair bit on
the show it's ridiculous yeah and this
is the problem is it's it's I'm just
like okay objectively in a thousand
years so you're going to Betty this
person it's got all these Sport and
achievements on the gra stor what a
great you know Women's Champion golf
bang bang bang bang bang and then they
do the and they're like these must have
been stupid cuz that's a
d they did not know the difference
between and and and and again if we
can't agree on simple things like you
know the basics then we've got no no
chance of solving the really complex
stuff that we've clearly got to get if
we're going to survive on the planet for
another 500 years I mean we'd be
fortunate at this rate Joey do you think
it's quite bizarre almost because like
you said football is in many ways the
ultimate meritocracy doesn't matter who
your dad is it doesn't matter your
background what color you are blah blah
blah you can either do it or you can't
and it's pure meritocracy and then on
the other side you've got this I mean
it's it's utterly bizarre isn't it yeah
it it is strange isn't it because you
know as say most sport is is meritocracy
the best person who gives you the best
chance of winning gets the Jersey
um which I
think is not a ra it's not radical it's
just common common sense I'm like yeah
you want the best people we know that
diversification I read a book called
teams of teams by uh General Stanley
mccristal and they talk about you know
diversity is massive in in terms of it
does help you you know get different
perspectives different we know it it
leads to better to Performance but
diversity for diversity s or quality for
you know quality inclusion for inclusion
say is bizarre you know the highlight of
this being the current uh she follows me
actually we woo with this um I don't
know where it's a real person but has
been um taken Mark Cuban on um about you
know saying Dallas Mavericks should have
she wants to play for the Dallas
Mavericks because they haven't got a
Chinese 5 foot2 Chinese girl in the team
you know you've got in your other
businesses and I I think it's somebody's
parody account but I think it's got
quite big traction it's she's still
Cubans actually was interacting with her
for a bit and has then blocked blocked
us so it's gone but again you
know the message we got to send to
people is work
hard be as be be as diligent as you can
in upgrading your skills and and if you
do that and you and you put the time and
effort in you will get rewarded and you
will get on but we're sending a wrong
message I think we're sending the
message of be lazy be controversial mhm
um be a victim cancel people be a VI
victim and what would that just I just
think we're just just going to society's
just going to spidal off the back of it
and you know I think I think we've I do
think we've gone past kind of that Peak
wokness when I'm watching the states now
um I've been you know I always watched
American kind of uh culture because it
ends up in some form of fashion by the
weird osmosis of tele television you
know uh uh um ruing our society when I
look at you know the the message the
Kardashians send to young girls I mean
it's just so so dangerous I think the
the worst kind of people you know change
your body you're not good enough alter
yourself you you
know you know these girls look up to
them you know if they release a a
mascara tens of millions of these young
kids are watching it and it over
sexualized and everything you know
basically make yourself a superstar by
doing a sex tape and then exploiting
everything that comes afterwards um and
yet to celebrate it and I'm like this is
just we're just sending the wrong
message we won't realize for 20 or 30
years what the consequences of this are
and obviously Yori brov and and the it
you know the the stuff that they' been
saying about kind of what the Soviets
were going to do to universities were
kind of seeing you know that kind of and
I know Peterson Jordan Peterson was
talking about you know language a long
time ago and he was really really strong
on not letting the W take control of
language and and we're seeing why you
know the the crazy situation we in
now for me I didn't think we'd be this
stupid cuz I I want to work on the
premise that most people are rational
and most PE people are reasonable but
what I'm finding now is and Co for me
was the big change point when I was
seeing people driving around in the cars
with a mask on and they were the only
person in the car I'm
like when I'm seeing people you know
banging pots and pandas and then getting
locked in the house and phoning um the
authorities on on the neighbors cuz
they've had three walks today I'm just
like where are we going and and it's a
strange I didn't get vaccinated
because I watched um the the the the
companies basically say if anything
happens we're not going to and I was I
got Co relatively early I was just
watching it unfold I was like there not
enough information here you know
anything I knew about vaccines and I
kind of read a book I should I shouldn't
have read it really called Merchants a
doubt about the toac industry and how it
kind of um you know corrupted the
medical industry to say smok was great
here and obviously we all now know that
not to be true and I just had this this
I was just like this just isn't right
this is this kind I didn't want to kill
anybody's Grand I didn't want to pass
the infection on as well you know so you
know I end up volunteering because we
got shut down in football obviously we
all got stopped so I end up volunteering
for the Royal volunteers and and you
know ended up doing a load of washing
and getting a few messages for for the
guy who who was living near me who
obviously did didn't have a washing
machine and would go to the lawn Dr so
obviously Co happening um and I didn't
obviously want to you know cause any
problems for society and and luckily got
Co so in early March
natural uh fought it off it was was not
nice lost me sense of smell taste for 10
12 days did feel different to the flu
yeah no we we had a a couple two or
three times and one of the two one of
them was really barely noticeable for me
the other two pretty brutal like it
wasn't a flu it was yeah I I felt that
like I was in the back Garden we'd been
shut down for Co and just felt really
really cold to the point where I ran a
hot bath and know you know the Bath's
hot you get in there and it felt
freezing but like steams coming off me
so I was like this is not right and he
felt like that for two days really cold
really like flu and then but the smell
and taste had
gone so that why would I need the
vaccine if me body had built up natural
antibodies towards it it doesn't stop
you getting it it doesn't stop you
passing like and then when they were
starting to say like you know for me the
big thing was when they started offering
people in America like beging and fries
and I was just like what's going on here
and then luckily I didn't you know
didn't need to get vaccinated to carry
on playing I probably would have done if
You' have said to me you need to take
this vaccine because we want to go back
playing we want to start the football
season back up and get the season
finished I probably would have taken it
because I'm that desperate to play
football and if the you know the club
doctor was telling me which I think's
gone on at lots of these clubs you know
I know they've put off the the vaccine
um conversation till after the general
election because it's clearly going to
go right across all parties um but and
and I I would have you know for the for
the pressures of our industry I probably
would have got at least one one
vaccination you know I've taken flu
vaccines if go if go on you know a Far
East trip or a go to the Amazon I would
take the required vaccines to not get
you know the the the tropical diseases
that are out there so I'm not anti
facts and by the grace of God if there
is a God um I didn't get injected and at
the time my wife was pregnant with my
youngest son etti and now and her family
were kind of in that limbo that everyone
was in trying to do the right thing and
a brother got uh vaccinated and got
rushed to hospital within 24 hours and
had to get his appendix out just you
know definitely as a as a um in response
to what what he' been injected with um
you know these the 91% of the UK I think
that was what a red had been vaccinated
at one dose at least so there's a lot
we're in the minority the people who
haven't been vaccinated so it's no good
going ha because you're not going to
you're in the minority and I think a lot
of good people have made poor decisions
because of the information that was at
hand or the pressure to keep the economy
moving or the jobs moving and I don't
think it's a case of going back and
punishing everybody you know the same
way I think we just have to draw the
line under it and it's easy for me to
say I haven't lost a loved one I wasn't
forced to bury a loved one behind the
plastic sheet or with a funeral of two
or three people I haven't had uh Co
injuries you know because I never took
the job the job so it's easy for me to
say look I think we have to just draw a
line and say I think a lot of good
people made bad decisions you know we're
all subject to change when new
information comes to light and I think
they try to do the right thing in the of
a global pandemic where the government
clearly were incompetent or incapable
and everybody was trying to do the right
thing to protect vulnerable people and
in the midst of that they've done
some um irreparable damage to
people's belief in in government to pe
people's belief in um Authority and also
to to people's um bodies and families
and and some people if that's happen to
you I'm not sure I would be able to
forgive and forget but do you remember
the Canadian trucker protest in 2022
where thousands of Canadians came out to
protest Co restrictions and vaccine
mandates now these protests lasted for
weeks and the people out on the streets
needed money as any Grassroots protest
would so people set up online
crowdfunding campaigns which raised
millions of dollars it was incredible
but those campaigns were closed down and
the money didn't get to the protesters
because the Canadian authorities started
to criticize the crowdfunding platforms
ramping up pressure on them to close the
campaigns the biggest crowdfunding
platform the one we've all heard of
completely capitulated to the demands
now this is where our partners gifs and
go come in they stepped in when the
other platforms backed off and raised
millions of dollars for the truckers
when they were criticized and dragged
through the Canadian courts gien go came
out and said they respect diverse views
and believe hope and freedom are values
worth fighting for this is why we're
proud to partner with them so if you
need to crowd fund for whatever means
the most to you then don't go to the big
Tech platforms go to give send go
starting a campaign on give Sendo is
easy and intuitive go to giv send go.com
today that's gend go.com to start
raising money for whatever matters to
you the thing that I noticed as well is
there was football before covid and
football after covid and I'm going to be
honest with you was someone who really
loved football really loved it from the
age of 8 78 years old mad Keem football
fan I'm not sure I like the football
after Co do you know why I'm going with
this well V's more prevalent Now isn't
it that's ruined it hasn't it you know I
think I think we have to accept that the
black lives matter thing was tapped on
the back of that don't forget we were
all kneeling I had to kneel because my
brothers and my cousins been involved in
a in a racially one of the biggest
high-profile racial MERS in in the
country imagine I the St when everyone
was kneeling so I was like they just cuz
they write whatever they write about me
anyway so I'm like well for me to kneel
for two seconds stops them calling me a
racist because that's what they would
have done
um and also if if I what I felt it was
is showing the black people and people
are colored in the where would you like
there's no you know you don't need you
don't need to do it every single week
and every single game is it kind of Got
Hijacked and then then I seen people
stop players sto doing it and I thought
well you know now there's no point us
carrying on doing it because there was a
lot of players of color who stopped
doing it said this is a lot of nonsense
it's been hijacked by people with filous
purposes and and it doesn't it doesn't
uh do the cause you know reducing racism
any any any benefit and I and I do agree
with you I think it fundamentally
changed those who were in the industry
because the amount of [__] I've had off
fans over the years Home and Away fans
by the way when when it's going well
it's great football but when it's not
going so well you know the the the the
people clearly let you know it is in
that regard through meritocracy
and players and fans and the wag just
players were getting paid and and fans
were kind of taken for granted it was
kind of like the clubs were trying to
exploit fans to get as much money out of
them payers players were had lost the
connection you know working class game
The Players because of the salaries
certainly at the top level and and even
cascading down filtering down you know
they were still earning a lot more than
the average person and I think that been
you know certainly for me it was kind of
like TV money was what was driving you
know the big salaries and it was kind of
like I got the Feeling players were like
[__] the fans [__] annoying in the
stadium and there was a bit of a
disconnect and then the stadiums were
emptied and I think everybody in the
industry realized just how important
fans in the stadium were if if not as
important uh as the players you know
what's the point in it's a Sunday League
match in essence if the fans aren't in
there you know they make it and what
what I think players realized in that
period was how fan noise and you know
the momentum the energy that fans can
can can bring can lead to incredible
performance that is just not reachable
without the live stadium uh audience so
I think from that regard for players I
think it was a really interesting reset
and I think players and people in the
industry really appreciated the fans in
the stadium what it takes to you know to
Shell out your our and wages and travel
to a stadium and support your team with
the energy and I think from that regard
it was really good cuz I think there was
there was a disconnect happening mhm and
I think that said that but I do agree
with you in terms of the product we came
out of um you know we we there's no
doubt that George Floyd black lives
matter think IR irreconcilably uh
disrupted our culture you know beyond I
think it had more impact than anybody's
even figured out here and it shouldn't
because
America is a you know there a completely
different entity to to to to to the UK
but then you know with social media and
YouTu and all of a sudden people who are
Bor who people who are unimportant or
unimpressive hijack
these um movements you know to add
pronouns on and add you know whether
it's Ukraine and anti you know whatever
it is anti-russia or Middle East now or
you know whatever Crusader is and and
the problem for them is they hijack and
and and and and they take so many
positions that eventually as we're
seeing now in some of the communities
the end up cannibalizing each other
because although they stood on the same
thing two years ago now they're in
direct competition you know so for me I
lowered the drawbridge you know in
football I would I was the one who' done
the first interview with Amal fashu
about her uncle killing himself who was
I think a gay footballer Justin no want
to do it she kept emailing me and I'm
like go and ask one of the other you
know the ones who'll big profiles who'll
do any you know who should really be
speaking out on this because they're of
color and and and it Justin's more ly to
them than than me and she just kept no
one would do I don't want to name the
players names but the big profile even
today ex players now but like massive
media profiles didn't want any part of
it I said why she's like well the
fearful that they'll get homophobic
abuse in the stadiums so I'm like well
if I get homophobic abuse in the
stadiums is a positive from what I'm
getting so and also my Uncle Tom's gay
and he was one of my heroes growing up
and I didn't know he was gay till I was
like 19 or 20 and it wasn't it at that
it wasn't okay to be gay in the ' 80s
and '90s certainly in rural working
class like uh offsprings of of Liverpool
you know so you
know Joe can we talk about that a little
bit yeah I'm just going to so what I was
going to say to you then is so I got
asked to do this interview yeah I didn't
want to do it cuz I it's not my course
I've got a gay Uncle it's nothing to do
with me she couldn't get anyone to do it
so I said to look I'll do it for you
because I'm not bothered about anyone
saying I'm gay and the off spin of that
uh I think it was for the BBC or
whatever she did it the off spin of that
was Paddy Power and Stonewall came to me
and said look we got this idea for
rainbow
lacers you we seen you do that would
would you be so I was like okay what is
this and and so I end up being the first
person to wear rainbow laces and got all
some of my teammates to do it and now
it's become the Premier Leagues it's t
taken on by them they never you know
when they put or never mention me that
would give me credit you know so they
don't want to give me you know it's like
let's just call him a bastard for all
those things but let's not uh you know
shine light on the on the stuff he's
used as profile for positive for so so I
end up do do that that's become a big
thing now so I actually lowered the draw
bridge because I was
like there's got to one in 10 men a gay
how many professional footballers is in
the UK lot of averages like just just
logic who says to you there's got to be
some Lads in the dress room I know for
for a fact I've played with with three
or four but they couldn't they w't out
they couldn't come out public publicly
why not Joey I just think for the abuse
that you would get in a football stadium
you know cuz like anything you know
youve seen it with you see the clip
going online yesterday about the guy at
he's doing BBC Radio Wales from the
Newport Man United game and he's saying
oh this is great the fans are singing
anony is the greatest you know the
Brazilian Winger yeah and when he's he
goes can you not hear it and as he slows
it down you can clearly hear them
singing anon's a
rapist which he's been accused off in in
in Brazil Anthony's the greatest is the
latest champ from the oh oh no it's not
great
[Applause]
sorry uh
apologies if you understand that and
then he realizes but obviously it's just
Brilliance in terms of he actually has
thought the fans singing there because
again football stadiums you know you
misbehave you can't tell 2,000 4,000
8,000 drunken football fans what to sing
and what not to sing and what spitters
so if if you think about
football concept this it's a working
class game so we still have a huge class
system in this country I think and I see
it every single day when I watch and I
see it especially now when I watch The
Guardian jist attack me Guardian that
was once in now I I been in the officers
when I was talking about um you know
quote N and I was going to art galleries
and I was talking about rembrand the
guardian were all over me when I was
doing Stonewall and rainbow the guardian
could you know I could have got my own
uh opinion column in there no problem
and then all of a sudden I take this
position of um the the class is right
wing I don't I don't I don't see I
suppose if you're that far left
anything's right you know um and again
you know you know take take the position
said my truth about what I feel about
the female uh stand of the commentary in
the men's game and also that it's it's
taken men with cred credibility and
Equity jobs that's what they're
forgetting you know a lot of white and I
don't want to be a victim here and play
in then as it but a lot of whx players
are no longer a viable option because
it's
not politically correct to have them on
the TV really so in the industry now if
you're an ex-player who's a white male
of a certain age you just wouldn't get
I've had so many people reach out to me
who obviously you know petrified to say
anything because there will be repay
ramifications of of like I'm seeing low
90% 95% positive in in in personal
feedback about 8020 on Twitter never
agree about 7 30 on Instagram they're
the only kind of ones a gauge and and
then I always think there's lots of
people and I've met these people who
come up to me in person they say I
completely agree with you but I can't
say anything if I said that I'd get
sacked by work and and they work for
like a car manufacturer like because
they're on like zero hour contracts
whatever or I can't say that because me
I get in a dispute with me partner or
but totally agree with you so I'm only
seeing a
small kind of synopsis of of people's
real sentiment and feeling as you're
saying you smelling it and sting it as
well and I think you know it's only one
thing here about female commentator in
the male game but clearly in society in
businesses across it this is um infected
for the negative a lot of these other
Industries so you know I'm seeing
because I get a lot of uh feed feedback
in terms of they've put me a lot of you
know racism misogynous whatever they
want to call me from day to day but they
haven't actually come for me on the
homophobic one the reason they can't is
because done the rainbow lasers campaign
they probably will after they still
attack me great um but now what you're
seeing in that Community cuz I interact
with these because I was the first PE to
to you know certainly in the modern ER
to put a you know to put put me balls on
the line so to speak to say we should
make it absolutely fine for the to be a
gay footballer clearly there's been
thousands of them but they haven't we
haven't made the
landscape
um safe enough for them to be able to
come out whilst they're playing I know
Thomas hbur and a few LS I think there
is a guy playing in the lower leagues at
Blackpool mhm um who who Who's who's
who's out but on the whole I think a lot
of people and I think if you're a good
player I think it would be wise at the
minute wrong but wise at the minute for
all manner of different things to to
stay in the closet is that really true
Joey because I I look I don't know the
game as well as you obviously uh
but I find it hard to imagine that in
the society that we live in now
thousands of people are going to chant
homophobic abuse at somebody in public
well youve seen someone do a monkey
scientist to a black player at cheffield
Wednesday last week so clearly they're
gonna because they say stuff designed to
he you so they they say the stuff
they've said like I remember getting out
of jail right came out of jail for
assault i' had a fight in the Lio City
Center my first game back was at the
Emirates I was on the bench Kevin Keegan
put me on the bench for Newcastle
against uh Arsenal was my reint
reintroduction to Premier League
football it's the the Emirates which is
a sanitizer Stadium you know it's soft
in terms of you know there's no
malevolence in that Stadium like some
stadi viral clip right here like look
it's it's a fantastic Stadium it's
filled with graphic designers yeah it's
bit it feels a bit manufactured and
forced to try to create an atmosphere in
there which is different to you know I'm
old enough to have played that hybrid
multiple times and really on yeah really
narrow pitch you know you can feel
people breathing when you're taking a
fro in all the corner you can feel you
can you know they can they can touch you
these old football Amper theaters the
modern state iums changed a little bit
now you know obviously you know they got
to got to up upgrade and I do think it's
for the best but I'm at the Emirates as
I say not the bowling ground not West
Ham or something where the fans are on
yet and I'm warming up and as I'm
warming up this guy is just shouting
abuse abuse abuse at me basically
because I've been to jail for assault
and he's but he's telling me he's going
to Slit me throat so he's saying to me
I'm going to Slit if I can if I come
here I'll slit your throat and and he's
sitting next to his son who must must
have been five six seven at the time
shouting his abuse at me and the reason
he's shouting abuse at me is because
I've been involved in a violent
altercation and as we talk to sh abuse
nobody around him's checking him like
everyone's kind of sitting there like
it's not happening and I'm kind of like
now there's part of me cuz I'm fighter
flight and I'm fight there's part of me
that's
like okay let let's see what this is
about like so I I would always T and
meet it head on look him directly in the
eyes because I'm like well if you said
this to me where you knew there was
going to be a chance of of you being
held accountable not that the fact that
you're sitting in a stadium in the stand
and there's stewards and there's a
there's advertising ordin and about five
rows a seat in between
me there's no way in the world you would
be able to do what you what you what you
professing that you're going to do to me
if you get your hands on me plus you're
sitting next to your son and like this
is meant to be a football stadium MH and
and that for me is is the absurdity of
of the world like of football times you
know you cannot sanitize football
stadiums you're going to get people
shouting mad stuff because it is it is
the modern version of a church in terms
of people go there
religiously it's everything to them you
know being a Liverpool fan a man united
fan what it's everything to them it
actually makes them a success so there's
lots of people who aren't successful but
support a successful team and they
almost become successful as a B brother
because they're a winner because they
support win winner team which is
peculiar it's there's not many there's
not many sports I think that have the
reach in the world that football has and
I think when used positively can be
incredible you know you look at I've
just read a book and I don't know why my
first war I can remember was the bolans
so I remember that being on the TV
obviously sloban mosovich and and and
all the kind of you know s Evo and the
UN stepping in and then the guy who
fixed me foot was a un uh doctor and
told me some of the stories graphically
what gone on you know the EIC cleans
and nut
and
Croatian football doing well you know
way Achi you know population of five
million producing Luca Modric Dava
Robert P could be and I remember the
Yugoslavian team breaking up because if
you ever remember the Euros Was Won by
Denmark who went in it Yugoslavia
disbanded and Denmark took the place and
end up winning I think in 1992 it was
yeah the Euros England were crapping it
the gra
Turner uh period where we were terrible
we didn't make the World Cup 94 so I my
Irish heritage kicked in I became an
irand fan 94 cuz England wen't there but
Italian 90 was my first World Cup I can
member but then there was two Wars at
the back end if you remember there
obviously the conflict in the Balkan
States Yugoslavia breaking up and the
first Gulf War um and I read a book
about it and actually the war was in it
took it started the rebellion and and
the revolution took place in the
football stadiums when I've got a boook
Yugoslavia politics and football because
I was like how is this how is this
country I wanted to know how it produced
the caliber of players because if you
look at Yugoslavia without a shadow of a
doubt would if Croatia have got to World
Cup finals and semi-finals
Yugoslavia with the talent pool he had
would have no doubt been very very close
to winning a major tournament so you
know they'd won I think the the Youth
Tournament preceding and and they were
they were they were about to become a
golden generation you know Croatia get
to the semi final of France
98 and you think you add in what is it
you've got Slovenia is it in there is it
Slovenia Serbia obviously Croatia Kosovo
Macedonia I think there's like six
countries in there and then when you
when you know football at the level I do
and you go through and you go oh pandev
played for Inter Milan and played for
Macedonia he would have played for that
and you know you know you would have had
an an incredible talent
pool and reading it for me made me
realize how important football is for
social debate it's been the place you
could go when the stars he were in or
when you know the the government was not
maybe how how you wanted it in
Yugoslavia and you could Rebel you could
you could you could group together you
could share ideas they they'd go and
travel to games you know it became quite
reol fans in Iran now chanting against
the regime and stuff like that and and
this is the thing where we have to be
careful with the sports washing you know
one of my clubs Newcastle bought by the
Saudis I'm like it doesn't really you
you know an ex man man city obviously
got a nation state owner in in in Abu
Dhabi government it is interesting isn't
it because there's that contrast a
contrast between like what some people
at the Forefront of let's say sports
coverage
say about you know they're signaling
virtue about this and that and g a good
so imagine for instance James Milner so
I see James Milner as like I played with
Millie at Newcastle never drank drinks
tea every like the ultimate professional
if you want to be a football if I if I'm
a manager and you say who can I what
attitude can I take and give to all my
players it's Milner gets the maximum out
of him so he's been forced to play in
the Premier League and he needs to take
an injection I don't know where he has
and hav't asked really this
but like so so dangerous now if he came
out and said look I've had a vaccine and
and I had this reaction to it and I
don't think you should get it think of
the the power that would have think how
dangerous that is for people who don't
want that to be the narrative yeah so if
you look at football now I had latis
talking I was listening to a podcast uh
with Matt on uh Michael Anthony because
I've done a podcast with him a while
back totally different energy to use you
guys interesting guy and and and latis
is is on there and he's talking about
how character and like footballers now
there's just no characters it's just
very very Bland and you get like a
Marcus rashford who goes on a you know
does the the the I think really good to
go and get the school dinners thing and
and holds the government accountable
there but it's very seldom you see them
come out and have and have a message I
do remember when I was growing up you
had kind of Robbie Fowler with the
Dockers
and I think because of the
way the salaries and the way clubs are
now and the media control and also the
all the training these players are given
they're just robots you know you see
interviews after the game you can almost
verbatim kind of predict what they're
going to say can't you you know you can
almost you can almost but Joe this is
what I was getting at right just
sanitized just boring uh well right
except it also seems to me that there
are some people who are allowed to
express whatever opinions they want do
you see I'm getting that so is a good
example of this right because this is
someone who expresses quite a lot of
opinions that to a lot of people in the
country are wrong or controversial or
whatever but it just seems like when you
say what you say about female pundits or
whatever shock horror outrage Etc G ler
can say whatever he wants while working
for the national broadcaster yeah and
again you do you know and I know there's
people within the the industry that kind
of find that uh absurd but then it's
it's about power isn't it really when
you think about it
so judg him from the outside I don't
know it looks like Gary's had a catar he
pretty much does what he wants at the
BBC because he's he's probably got them
by the short and KES you know if you
don't do this I'll piss off and work for
CBS or I'll go and work for Al jazer or
I'll go and work for the highest bid at
Amazon or whatever so he's obviously in
a
position where they're petrified to
losing him um and again you know I know
a bit more about that that character
than kind of what to get up to and and
if people actually knew the truth about
what he get what he's done and what he
get up to it wouldn't last five minutes
you know with the virtue signal and yeah
I mean
absolutely like
Despicable uh and then to say the stuff
he says I'm like but that's a lot of
these people Joey because you know
Jordan Henderson you know he was an
lgbtq role model coming out and you know
talking about acceptance and whatever
else Saudis wave a 350 Grand a week
tax-free salary in his face and he's see
you later boys I'm off to I'm off to
Saudi Arabia yeah and look I mean care
I would [__] take that deal again you
have to be careful telling the truth
because you know you can be principal
and stand for something but again it's
out the window if if you take the the
biggest bundle of cash isn't it you know
so so again you know do you think he's a
bad person no because if someone offers
you that I mean he's it's not lasted
long as he's on his way back oh he's
gone to Ajax now so you
know most people are virtuous until
enough money's put in Fr in the
face we'll get you back back to the
interview in a minute but first let me
recommend an incredible alternative to
coffee that will give you that all day
energy without the Jitters in a
delicious hot drink mud water is made
with four functional mushrooms don't
make things out of dysfunctional
mushrooms and only a fraction of the
caffeine you'll find in a cup of coffee
so you'll get that natural energy
without the crash each ingredient was
added for a purpose cacao and chai for a
hint of caffeine and hot chocolate like
flavor Lions man for Focus cceps to
promote Natural Energy and both Chara
and RI to support a healthy immune
system is quality stuff and tastes like
cacao and chai had a baby why you'd want
to drink a baby is anyone's guess but
there we are plus it's Whole 30 approved
100% USDA certified organic non-GMO
glutenfree vegan and kosher so not only
does it taste great you can also give it
to your woke mates right now you can
save $20 plus get a free sample of
creamer and a free fro by going to the
link in the description below or heading
to
mwr.com
trigonometry that's
mud
wt.com
trigonometry to save $20 on your
subscription and claim your freebies and
now back to the show for me I I'm
looking I I don't value money I have no
like it doesn't make me happy and I've
only only know that because I've not had
it and had it mhm so you know it's EAS
life's well easier if You' got it like
I'd rather have it than not have it you
know so it can't ever be Grudge anybody
but it can't
be why you do what you do like I made
one move in my career for money and I
hated it hated every moment moment of a
QPR and I've been vocal and and a lot of
the QPR fans don't like me because I've
said I only sign for the club because of
the contract there and and and I didn't
enjoy me time there because I knew i'
joined for the wrong reasons it wasn't I
didn't like the club or the people and I
had a great moment with winning a
playoff final with in the last minute
when we down to 10 men stuff 805 I'll
never forget like life airing moments
and always looked to that club
positively but because I was honest and
I said I I sign for the money know I was
leaving Newcastle and I fell out with
Mike Ashley the owner there and and I
went to the highest bidder sorry a
merary like you know at that point I was
30 you know you I know I haven't got 10
15 years left I know I 35 36 whatever
you know very ages my sport
unfortunately um very ableist as well
once your body fails you you're gone
know as much as I'd like to stay there
for another 10 to 15 years I'm hoping
with the if this di continues you have
to go for an old gray white person in
don't think that's ever going to happen
you're going have
to I'm in the category now of as they
say and we'll get back to it of white
male and stale yeah so as I said said to
you when I'd said what i' said about the
women lots of EX players lots of EX
media personalities have reached out to
me and said look you can't quote me on
this but this is the landscape this is
what's going on you know behind the
cameras there's no Dei all the people
who are producers executive producers
financially uh beneficial jobs are all
white they all but everyone in front of
the camera or where it matters have
obviously they're petrified now because
of the George Floyd black lives matter
at all the Marchers and the Petrified
that the woke mob t on them and then
shut them down and if if they they're
like how do we defend our Ivory Tower
right let's let's let's diversify in
front of the and and all the people
who've got Equity who've who've been in
our organization and and and and and
done great work for years now are gone
because this doesn't fit the public uh
face and arm of of our
Corporation and for me I'm just like
every time you turn the TV on I'm like
[__] hell like so so what it's done
and this is the bad the bad thing for me
I'm driving I shouldn't say this out
loud but I ended up in the house and I'm
unemployed at the Minnesota you
obviously do a lot of daytime TV safe
and so I'm watching some documentary
finishes and I flick over and I don't
know why I like this but every now and
again if the bows is on you know the
crown green balls I find myself watching
it I don't know why I find it incred
employment will do that to you no no
I've play every a lot of pubs by ours
used to have a crown green bowling uh
thing in the backyard so and there was a
couple of lads in our road who whose dad
played Crown green balls so I wasn't
into Crown green balls there was one in
our Park um but we used to use it for
football which obviously wasn't great
for the for the because it was the best
saers oh yeah you know we only had
trainers on we didn't wear boots on or
anything but we would get chased off by
the by the park keeper if he seen us on
there but we would play on it and and
every now and again we mate would bring
us balls and you'd have a game and it is
actually a fascinating game if you can
if you if you play only after an hour
you wouldn't want to play as a career I
wouldn't certainly any you know so I end
up flicking over and I'm watching the
balls and there was a woman cooms on the
balls okay and I started thinking to
myself all these women in in football
and they're usually wrong so I wonder if
there's a bowling ex player like me
who's played balls for years who's now
sitting in front of the tell going mad
because she is technically incorrec in
in her analysis of the crown green balls
and then I was driving yesterday and um
was it yesterday sat and I flicked Radio
5 on to try and get the footy commentary
on and it wasn't it was the net ball um
New Zealand against England was on the
live commentary which you can imagine it
was quite rivetting for a radio
commentary and it was two female comms
and
cooms but as they talking I was the same
I was like this could be waffling sh I
I've no longer any trust in other sports
female commentary because I
feel the ones we've got in the sport
that I'm I'm I'm I'm known for I've got
credibility
in if if we work on preo's LW of 8020
80% of the time the poor or incorrect
there is some good women pundits out
there not denying that but we've got
Overkill now there's too many and and
lots of them aren't good and you can't
remove them because if they come with a
couple of box six and they play certain
cards which lots of them do they're
actually really really difficult to
remove cuz they Sue yet and they go down
all the you know you seen with en who
sued sewer me she's joined with Jeremy
Vines lawyers to sue me so I got a
letter they kindly sent me a message on
Instagram to tell me I was going to get
it which is obviously uh what a lawyer's
contact so Jeremy Su so Jeremy sued me
for bike NS saying I'm I'm calling him a
pedophile or whatever and I'm not I'm
like no for me nons and about on a bike
with camera on your helmet trying to get
people points he's on his phone at
traffic is a peculiar way to spend your
day yeah um and then he asked me to
after I first said this I got so so how
this happened I I wasn't planning this I
knew this would be a topic that would
cause outrage women's comy because so
many people were pissed off with the
standards of and it was just annoying
people so I said to Noah and Josh we're
going to launch podcast I said I'll do
this 15th for Jan I'm going away on all
day I get back about 10 for Jan I'll
talk about it here so that was the plan
and then I Jo I've joined the snooker
League to get me competitive fix with
with me mates in the winter so we play
snooker on a Wednesday and it's in
working men's club in around uh the area
I'm all X mine and Villages so it's like
£150 a p which you won't understand if
you in London but it's like you can't
spend your money in there you but and
they're all you know ex labor clubs or
conservative clubs or like but but the W
and Men's
Clubs and Amazon were doing the games
that on that Wednesday so every game you
could watch and everyone had a different
commentary team so whilst the other Lads
are playing I'm waiting for me game I'll
cut the paints and then I played I'm
like what the [__] you what they on
about every time I kept changing the
tell over because they were that bad
played The Game come back and now about
five or six p in and I ended up sending
that tweet because I was like [__] what
what are he on
about then I went to bed that night and
I got up the next day I tear me phone
off to the Avalanche of wokeness
attacking me and I thought oh [__] I'm
I've got two options here I had
to say apologize for what I've tweeted
and say I didn't really meant it I was
playing SN I had a few points or
whatever or I actually do mean it and
[__] which is my
take um so my take was that P Morgan
reaches out to me and says look do you
want to come on and defend you know I'm
like I'll come on no problem and I I
didn't think it was going to be what it
was CU he didn't tell me anybody else
was coming on he said be 15 minutes I'll
ask you a few questions I thought it'd
be quite safe cuz he's aligned with this
anti-woke policy and a go on and and it
was obviously an ambush set for me which
I knew I said to Noah this won't be
straightforward even no p is there'll be
some there's something coming here so I
was pacing around before trying to think
of the attack what's the attack going to
be where's it coming from who's it going
to be I do the face bit and if you if
you know if you've seen the interview
after 15 minutes says we're going to
come back after a break and we're going
to have three female ex players on so
I'm like so I'm like I'm off I was
shouting I'm going because he didn't
tell me come back on and it was Bianca
West with off Sky some other woman who T
in the [__] foot football podcast had
an interesting football inconsequential
and a young girl who's an anti anti
feminist called pale Davis who Who's
online is YouTuber I've never met I
don't know YouTube I'm a 41 year old ex
footballer no no no listen bi do you
think the Bianca can I just ask you a
question and I respect your opinion
massively I respect your opinion
massively do you think the women's game
and the men's game is the same
game the laws of the game are exactly
the same the same rules apply know
whether it's yellow card red card
offside you can read the game it's still
EXA exactly the same there's two goals
and 11 players play have you ever been
tackled at full speed about that have
you ever been tackled at full speed by a
f grown man and
theoc
evolves anything to do with it you seem
to have changed your opinion Joey when
you were talking PE earlier you had a
problem with women who to talk about the
game
didn't to talk about the game and now
you're saying the game's different what
you have a problem with he's changing
his mind he's changing his mind all the
time have you got a problem with the
journalistic coverage or have you got a
problem with the playing of the game
please don't all talk over each other
you're just shouting at me I can't hear
you being a top player doesn't mean
you're going to conversation this is
becoming a
fast the face Bianca comes on and she's
just attacking me just just coming for
me was kind of I'm just sitting there
smiling cuz I'm like you you've done my
work for me I don't even have to say
anything like there's going to be so
many people who are now in my Camp
because of the stance you've take there
was another woman they tapped on second
who was trying of like get involved she
was a bit politer so I expected pale to
come on and she was I was like who's
this American she must be really smart
she's going to put a hole in me yeah so
I'm like what the other two didn't
really they were just confirming why
women shouldn't really be talking about
football really or or certainly about
the men's game and then pale comes on
and was like you not listening to him
and she'd actually taken the time to
listen was like no no he's not saying
that he's saying not saying women out of
football which I'm not saying far from
it some of the some great friends of M
in football at women but what I'm saying
is underqualified women shouldn't be
shouldn't be in there because they're
taking qualified men's jobs and I just
think that's wrong you know men mainly
in
football um have played the game mainly
or like there is the other exception
who've become exceptional but on the
whole it's it's people who've played the
game MH and if you put a lot of women
who play football are lesbians to be
honest you know it's not feminist women
it might be a bit more now it's a bit
cooler but it's usually lesbians M who
play women's games so they're not going
to have kids unless they adopt and do
madon or Angelina Jolie and kind of do
that virtue S one so you're taking away
men's jobs who've got equity in the game
Who cre now Beyond them because the body
can't do it anymore and they're Bread
Winners they usually got kids to feed
and families to to look after and
because it doesn't fit this cool agenda
of having a female on there or a person
of color on there or a homosexual on
there or whatever it is or a transexual
on there all of a sudden they're in
capacity is gone and the amount of
people honestly God of X players and I'm
saying would you say and they said can't
say it publicly latis goes on about the
the people dropping down dead and he's
contacted the PFA and FIFA Pro and he he
tells a great story about it and say way
way more cred credible than me in this
space and you know when when I when I
look at the attacks on him you know he's
not me he's very well behaved he's one
of the most loyal players I've ever
known didn't leave Southampton when he
could have gone anywhere a true
individual Channel Islander you know so
so um I found out today they're actually
called
donkeys weirdly because that that's
stubborn which fits for Matt's
personality because um he's he's he's
taking a stance and I think it's cost
him his media career
and further opportunities beyond that
and the amount of um women I see it in
in those roles who have taken men's jobs
now those women must be the best of the
best mhm cuz they're on the best shows
doing the best matches and they're not
very good on the whole some are but it's
in the
minority they could be commentating on
the women's game where they're credible
they could be building making the
mistakes that they're making on the TV
and the men's game now and getting
ridiculed for it and getting abuse
online and having to close the profiles
in the women's game and eventually
someone will go you know what he's
really good let's get on the men and
that's the way I think it should work
the cream should rise to the top they've
got enormous credibility in there
but they've got none in the men's game
absolutely zero and and any man
ex-player who tells you the women's a
take women commentators or pund to
takeen seriously he's a liar he's a liar
and and and I'm telling you there's none
of them that take it serious it's just
they want to keep the job like you can
see on the overlap all the stuff they
they don't think that deep down but
they're getting paid for it and they've
got profile and they've got power so you
can't blame them Gary L I don't I don't
um I don't know how he gets away with
what he gets away with in the see
because it's it's obviously taxpayer you
know through the license fee funded but
again I would imagine that he he just
it's checks and balances isn't he
there's no checks and balances on him
and that was evidence the other day when
the way Rooney tweet was put on by BBC
sport about the peaky blinders and he
came and said get it taken down and
within 15 minutes it was down when you
see the uh sports Personality the is
it's a joke like but when you see
obviously the keeper when you see who's
at the front and center of that there he
is again again you know the the woke
diversity nonsense that you see in there
is just running them mo and even when I
look at X teammate of mine who've
attacked me who we didn't like each
other when we
played and when I look at the Personnel
who were in certain roles it's so racist
it's untrue what you mean by that Joey
well it's racist because it's against
white people so that that exclud them
white people specifically because
they're white so we did that if that was
done any to any other race we got both
we go oh well you know white people have
owned slaves and had to I'm like I
haven't I'm from Liverpool workingclass
estate Irish immigrant family you know I
haven't owned any tobacco plantations or
uh cotton plantations and you know that
wasn't me from where I know they they
landed aristocracy who were sitting in
the houses of Lords or in Bingham
Palace you take it up with them you know
I I I I don't get how we've gone from
you know 82% of the British population
are white and yet we're
excluding them based on the fact that
the whes what can you do about being
born in Britain unfortunately there's
not enough Sunny yet to get any over
shake like once we exclude people on col
it's just bad we would never do it um
you know to to any other race I think
it's fundamentally wrong to do it and
it's happening to white people and
everybody's just kind of g off well you
know the white people have done some bad
things in the past I'm like yeah so what
you can do what the [__] you want to
them now you can pretty much just
exclude them from um having the
opportunity to use Merit and and and use
their ability to get as far as they can
in life and I just think it's wrong
absolutely wrong at its core uh I I
quite agree with you Joey there's one
thing that I really wanted to talk to
you about which is mindset okay what
makes a premier league footballer why is
it that some people who have the ability
I'm thinking of someone like rll
Morrison who was at West Ham and
probably the most R QPR yeah who was one
of the most talented footballers of his
generation if that's what Rio said and
lots of other people me player yeah
really talented why is it someone like
him never made the top and yet there are
other people who were less talented like
your Gary Neville who then go on and win
Champions Leagues twice leagues etc etc
yeah look to win trophies you've got to
be at certain clubs mhm you know there's
only so many teams that can win a trophy
at the top level so there so many teams
that can win the Champions League you
can probably count them on two
hands similar with when it comes to the
Premier League you might get the odd
Leicester who you know the odd cave ball
team but on the whole pretty much all
the top leagues in in all the top
countries go to a certain select amount
of clubs so to play for a certain team
at the right time can mean you end up
with a trophy lad in career or like use
latis for example clearly a player
capable of um magic but won't have won
much cuz he stayed at Southampton and
constantly fought relegation and never
went to you know join Chelsea or
Tottenham or Liverpool or man united so
so massively decrease your chance of
winning all these trophies like Harry
Kane prime example had to leave
Tottenham to go and try and get the
trophies he feels like he's going to
need to be held in the same esteem as
some of the greats that have played the
game um you know playing for Bayern
Munich I do think is is a chance for him
to cement his his legacy he
obviously negates his chance of beating
shira's uh Premier League record but
again he's probably good enough player
to come back at some point in the next
two three four years and and still get
to that record I think um and then what
people what people miss with footballers
is addictive
personalities who get ad addicted to
football at a at a young age and then
then dedicate everything in their life
to that in terms of you know every W and
moment you know remember me being in
school all I'm thinking about is the
training I've got to do after school
finishes or the game I'm going to play
in or what the teacher talking I'm
trying to pay attention but I'm thinking
about the game I'm going to play in or
training I've got that night for you
know for Everton's Academy at the time
or man City's Academy and what people
miss with footballers is it takes
enormous discipline over a long period
like I sacrifice being a teenager
which is probably a good thing cuz there
wouldn't only been trouble or the stuff
that's out there and I look at all my
close PE group I grew up with who've had
have been killed
killed been involved in uh crime at at a
high level and I've either had to leave
the country or us living in other
countries now that you know so I go well
that was that was the kind of group I
was in luckily for me at
156 my mom and dad got divorced at 14 I
went to live with my grandmother who was
a lot more strict than my mom so I was
kept on a real tight leash my brothers
went they stay with me Mom on the
council estate and I just moved off but
was with me gr and she would go when I
was at that age where I could have just
slipped like I'd say I'm staying in my
mates and I was going fishing or [__]
about with me mates and she'd got if I
said I was staying in my mate she'd want
to speak to my mate's mother or she'd
visit the house to make sure I was there
which my mom never would have done and
loads of people's parents didn't so they
could fall in the cracks of
being you know little bit mischievous as
a youngster I couldn't cuz me gr had
literally if I if I said I was um
staying somewhere or was like coming in
she'd come and get me and pull me out of
it only happened once twice and never
done it again CU I thought she'll
[__] drive me out make a show me and
she done that to me dad but but it work
with me cuz I had something to to get
after a career I was touching go for a
long period but something to get after
and then it was the sacrifice you know
16 17 18 people are want to drink drug
exper experiment girls whatever's coming
in I knew if I did that I wasn't going
to be good enough to make it cuz I'd
seen lots of people get in trouble with
all of those viers who were talented
better players than me and it didn't
make it Revel you know would be in that
category of incredible player play with
rll QPR strange character in terms of
just been allowed to get away with lots
because of his talent he actually just
needed someone really strong with him to
to show him he didn't need a dis larian
but he needed someone to to you know I I
believe men men need male mentors who
[__] up and change the lives like
Blacky for me was one Peter K from Sport
and chance Clinic former uh drug and
alcoholic changed my life fundamentally
um and when you when you meet these
older people who aren perfect who say
look I've felt that and I've done that
and I've [__] up and I've done
actually 10 times worse than you there
you know I've done ex all of a sudden
you you realize oh my God
like I'm not a bad person I've just made
a mistake here and I think when we go
through in the world and we try and make
everyone perfect and you can't make a
mistake I just think it's really
dangerous cuz for me life is a series of
[__] up and trying to improve you
know being prepared to fail whether
that's on your bench press if you're
trying to lift or in a race or I think
failure is very very important and lots
of failure obviously you don't want
catastrophic failure because you know
you don't recover from it but I I think
you got to put yourself in a position to
fail you know to be ridiculed to you
know you it's the only way for me you
make real progress and when I look at
like a g Neville that you spoke about
feel like I'm going around a little bit
Gary Neville would be somebody who did
everything right trained slep at every
front right and that increases your
chances of making it it's very very
difficult to make it because someone can
tackle you and that's the end have 15 16
17 or you might grow you know your
genetic constraints might kick in or you
know a managable might in fancy you know
in a key window where you need an
opportunity to play so it is finally
balanced but I think the people who have
a fantastic attitud like you know Gad
Neville would I would say would be you
know like almost like a perfect a prefec
in school he would do everything he
could you know that's not every
character cuz sometimes as you know with
great football with that addictive
personality comes quinessa gazer clearly
incredible football based on his his his
quaky mindsets but obviously that's
caused him a lot of problems in in his
life and I think someone like that you
know Gaza probably needed an Alex Fs and
type role model and everyone thinks if
he de sign for Man United that would
have been different for Gaza but then
you're right to point out R Morrison was
under [__]
Tage and I've seen a lot of my you know
the way I'd behaved as a younger person
where what you were actually wanting was
someone to Mentor you because what we're
all looking for is structure and
boundaries and this is why I worry about
Society now if you just left you know
the Evergreen thing I don't know whether
you've seen this did you see that we'
had all the people when people when kids
are telling adults what to do I think
the lunatics are now running the Asylum
and now remember being 20 me I'm on a
hero's journey I've just got in the face
team at Man City I start getting into
you know 20 to 24 is is when my world
kind of changes in terms of I become
what I've always dreamt of becoming and
I get financially rewarded for that and
I remember the arrogance of of of me
thinking I [__] crack this or know
everything I look back at it now think
my God how naive and how stupid you was
but I remember the energy I had that you
know as said I turned aist in that
period I'm like no I've done all this
reading and you think you know
everything plus you're really really
motivated in terms of you know people go
to war in them in them age categories
you come out of University or you come
out of school and whatever and you're
ready to take the world on and you think
you know everything and it's only when
you're 40 or you're 30 you realize how
stupid you was in your 20s you know you
only have to look back at Old 40s to see
the clothes you've got on your haircuts
Etc um and and that energy now is going
unchecked cuz that's scaring 30 40 50 60
year olds to death and the Petrified to
say anything so now the lunatics are
running the Asylum that's what we've got
and and again I do think Society has
broken down because people have
forgotten what it's like to get slapped
or punched in the face you know you you
do some of these radical things that
these are doing and someone punches you
in the face once you don't do it again
no because you think [__] hell don't
don't fancy that you know don't agree
with it but I got hait as a kid you know
when I stepped out of line I got whacked
it stopped me stepping out the line
again now I I don't bring my kids up in
in in that world you know because I've
learned a different strategy and you
know spoke to Great mentors and read
lots of books and I'm trying a different
way with it and and I want to have a
different relationship with my kids but
then when I see the world that we in I'm
like this is probably a this is probably
a factor that kids now are just going
unchecked you know University just
running over the professors and it is
this Yori BR of B bman off yeah of of
this um when I look at it and I don't
know loads about it I've just there a
few guys talking about it I'm like I
know it's what Peterson's been saying
the universities have been hijacked and
these
Mega
young really really want to take the
world on and make their stamp and change
the world people are just so confused
and they're just running rough shot
against everything and they're
actually pulling the very Institutions
and the fabric of society that we need
to function help
are down and it's
causing irreparable damage I think to to
some institutions and and if we're not
careful you know I didn't
think East Germany the star I'm always
like how the Stars he made the how did
did onethird of the population you know
opt into spying on and waiting for the
for the State against the people and Co
made me realize actually really really
quickly really really quickly a minority
can take over a majority it was the
stuff you guys were speaking about I it
on the little Cliff I
thought and I didn't I like oh yeah
actually if we don't if we don't stand
up and say our truth and even if you get
excommunicated I'm I've been the black
sheep so I'm cool I'm like listen I'm
just on the nauy step again I've been
here loads of times and what a l out on
that step when when you're ostracized
and you get out there cuz you're a bad
person all you want to do is fit in CU
we're quite tribal you know we're Prime
primates I believe hierarchal
chimpanzees you know um Darwin Fe
Evolution had a huge effect on me you
know I'm still as I say it made me an
atheist Dawkin Etc uh Christopher
Hitchin is a huge uh influence on me but
a few things have happened and I've met
people and it's just kept me agnostic
like it's just a few weird things where
I'm like hopefully and it gives me great
salvation at this moment moment cuz I'm
like hopefully there is something um out
there that is has got a good you know if
there is a heaven or whatever it is and
there is a God and he's got this
ultimately he'll allow good to Prevail
and when I look back across humanity and
you see you know the Nazis get seen off
you think what go what it must have been
touch and go for large periods of that
early part of the 19 39 to you know mam
was born 42 it doesn't look until like
42 43 and and you know when the Russians
and and get involved that it kind of
goes away from uh Hitler but when you
look at kind of history and you look at
um good prevailing you know I know
there's been mass murder and genocide in
you know Cambodia or the Native
Americans and but I do believe good gets
through and you know it's the Peterson
stuff of it only works if you can speak
truth to power you know Putin for
instance thought he was going to going
to take Ukraine in what two three days
because he's in a vacuum where nobody
will tell him the truth for fear of the
consequence you're not allowed to tell
the truth to power because if the if the
power doesn't like the truth that's the
endia you know stal and you know all
these dictators or whatever you know we
actually have an episode with a
historian about talking about that very
thing it'll come out after yours but
we'll send it to you well and I seen use
it into world history I didn't want to
take you down it's RIT all guys
sorry so so so for me you know if you
cannot
if you can't TR speak the truth to power
a eventually it's going to disintegrate
which is what I think Putin's two in a
bit years in now to a three-day War you
know he thought the ukrainians were
going to roll over almost like the the
French and wave them into to Paris you
know and obviously the adverse uh
scenario he's in now is that that that
hasn't happened and that has hasn't
happened because of the way he's
constructed the world that he's in you
know no no one's telling them the truth
and and and again you know for me we
have to I agreed with what you said and
I don't think it's perfect our country
by the way but I've traveled around the
world and I've seen lots of places and
look we've got loads of work to do but
but I think it's a a fantastic country
for for for many many reasons po Oland
as soon as I reply to your thing people
come back at me all the all the things
were not doing so well training times po
all but see people get confused about
this and you were talking about this
from the personal level as well just
because something isn't perfect or a
person isn't perfect doesn't mean
they're a bad person it means they've
got things they can work on but the the
way I feel about the way people talk
about this country and they talk about
America and the West more broadly it's
like if you talked about your partner
your wife your girlfriend in the way
that people talk about their country
people would say you're an abuser if you
talk that way about your wife right but
but but we for some reason we're allowed
I mean of course we're allowed to we all
have free speech I just mean I mean we
are allowing people to get deluded about
the reality of the place in which they
live and then they go out and they say
all these things that's not to say we
haven't got problems I have to disagree
with I don't think we've got free speech
I don't honestly I I I I would like to
think we have but then you know I've
found out recently we don't you know
people want to sue you and I'm I'm you
know I kind of get it but I I've spoken
to people when people have written
pieces about me in the past and I'm like
what is this liable and they're like
well this is how much it's going to cost
and in the end you're like um what's
it's just wasted resource you know the
only people winning it is is loyers and
then when you get these lawyers of no
win no V kind of buzzing around you know
looking for outrage and looking to you
know give themselves where I find it
peculiar um you know as say I do believe
as uncomfortable as it is you have to be
able to speak the truth to power and the
problem we've got at this moment in time
is you know
power is just not listening is it's just
it's you know you know it's not
listening to to people and I I've never
ever thought we'd be in a position
where you know the
government are stealing from the people
like the PPA stuff is just probably the
tip of the iceberg if they get into it
you know track and Trace what was that
three billion what the [__] was that all
about like you know another two and a
half billion to Ukraine this keep going
in until you I'm like what what are we
doing like the Russians I don't agree
with Putin I do think he's a bad man but
to control a country like that the same
way with Sadam Hussein you need bad
people you can't I mean I'm Russian and
I really don't like Putin but it's not
untrue well again but you need bad
people to control
big massive um what would I call it like
ethno diverse groups religiously diverse
groups across the
S you can't expect a nice guy to to hold
that together you know now I'm you know
Putin's the extreme example of that you
know don't disagree with him you have
his enemies have a funny um um habit of
falling fall Windows all blowing up in
ples you know but I was watching the
whole progan I'm like speaking to a
couple of my pal who who went with me
who were one's an ex SAS SAS and one's
ex doctor in the SBS and I'm like I'm
back and forth and with them on the wall
like I've never seen anything like this
also when the you know the the gas pipes
getting blown up I'm like who's this who
who's who's done this is this a good
thing is is this a bad thing and
then you know I think Society has to
it's the Peterson one again of it's it's
when really dangerous men are capable of
it but don't use it there has to be a
deterrent like you know you have to
think if I do this there's going to be a
consequence now if there's no deterrent
as
Californian retail industry is finding
out you know there has to be a deterrent
us just say well we're not going to
prosecute anyone who steals less than
$950 well great my dad worked as a
security guard W to go off on a tangent
in in a big supermarket chain uh just
before he
retired and he said none of the security
guards would stop people who were
shoplifting because they'd say put can
you put that down cuz if they touch them
there's a completely different um case
opening up where he could be sued so
you're your security guard in in a in a
supermarket chain stopping people
shoplifting but you can't go anywhere
and need them now my dad's difference he
would and then in the end he's like I'm
get I got in trouble so he said you're
asking me to stop people stealing from
in the shop and I'm trying to stop them
and if if I put my hands on them to to
take the stuff off them I get sued so
what and the job doesn't pay enough for
for yeah and it's this this is just this
strange strange world of consequences
for some things and no consequences for
other things and it's like okay like we
so it's you know the polican being one
you know seeing you know the kind of
two-tier police and somebody is able to
shout obscenities and then I seen I
don't know you've seen this clip of the
looks like a volunteer police officer
telling someone to not to sing a church
or a gospel song yesterday no Miss
you're not allowed to sing church songs
outside of church grounds by the way
outside that's fine you're not allowed
she just said you're not allowed to sing
songs outside of church out church
outside of church grounds unless you
have a unless you authorized by the
church do this kind not saying anything
anymore are you saying that you don't
care about the Human Rights Act you're
lost so you know it's okay for certain
religions to pray outside and take over
spaces and and and and but it's not for
other religions and and the police are
policing one and arresting people and
rounding them up and allowing you know
it's it's the I mean there was a woman
we've seen that as well you know BLM
demonstrations prime example yeah I mean
there was a woman who was arrested for
praying silently outside an abortion
clinic just like s her head can I please
ask you to step away from here and step
outside the exclusion
Zone engaging but you've said you're
engaging in prayer which is the offense
silent prayer no but you are still
engaging in prayer it is an offense I
disagree you're totally right Joey we're
running out of time in the thought
police thing if you's playing s ad you
are now in all world that's right that's
what I'm saying um and it's really
interesting talking to you this we could
talk for another hour I actually was
going to ask you about you know you've
talked a lot about violence in your
childhood and dealing with all of that
and obviously I'm sure it plays into the
young man that you then were and stuff
like that I would have loved to talk to
you about that maybe we'll we'll come
back you come on mine and we can we love
to love to do that but anyway we're
going to go to locals with questions
from our audience in a second but before
we do we always wrap up with the same
question which is uh according to you
what's the one thing we're not talking
about that we really should
be oh um the one thing I haven't I've
spoken about a lot recently on on
certainly on Twitter because I'm opening
up a few uh uh fronts in terms of uh
discussions for the podcast later uh for
me one massive one would be the kind of
tax situation and how many of the you
know big taxpayers or people who should
be paying a lot of tax in this country
are just avoiding just loopholes for the
rich to get out of it and yet you know
I'm someone who's paid an enormous
amount of tax you know that that's where
I think you know the Premier League
salaries going north is a great thing
because 45 to 50% of them will go in tax
and National Insurance you know
harland's on 900 Grand a week well
that's great for the tax because you get
half of that um and it's you know your
Starbucks your Amazon your you know your
big corporations as well as these big
wealthy guys whether that's you know the
sunak uh Dynasty or the Rees MOG Dynasty
who just
blatantly are refusing to pay tax and
because they've got the big charted
accountants that they pay fan
financially a lot of money too it's kind
of seen as okay it's it's almost white
collor
crime but you know because it's VI all
these legal loopholes it's it's great
and I and I think if we actually got
into the nitty-gritty of that and people
paid the right am I'm not saying they
should get tax I don't like you know I
don't think any population should be
taxed more than
25% I just don't I don't think you know
to tax High earners more than for doing
well not necessarily down with that but
I think if if we were to go and look at
um our tax structure I think a lot of
the uh money we could get back on that
could be utilized well probably not with
this [__] government they' only
probably siphon it off into the offshore
accounts um or to the cronies to buy by
yacht um but but I think you know the
people who are profiteering from from
the people of this country who were
giving us McDonald's and Starbucks and
fatty foods and all the problems that
arise from from their profiteering I'm
not saying they're wrong to do it
because in a capitalist structure it's
up to people whatever they want to do
you want to eat fast food or whatever
but all the benefits that their money is
making them offshore is not going into
the na who are dealing with the problems
that they're causing with you know the
products they're making a huge profit
from so for me I think we need to get
get hold of our tax you know tax you tax
the poor all the time you know you Les
driving in here like you're taxing the
poor and the working all the time what
about these you know the rich are still
getting richer like that yeah we've got
to gear our country towards if you do
really well out the country and you earn
a few quid you should look at it and be
say look I'm I'm delighted to pay me tax
I've always seen as a badge of honor you
know I'm a working-class kid who's
paying me tax now there's been times
where I've been offered you know and it
was there's one of them that you should
get into that's wiped out all the
footballers that's why you seen a lot of
footballers going bankrupt of the
generation before mine because the
government actually had a scheme where
you could invest in the British film
industry and it would obviously offset
some of your tax yeah and and and the
bank offer that to us well well well
again there's a lot of them out there
and the banks and all that All In
Cahoots with it so they all they were
all in cahoots the government it was
hmrc regulated or backed and then 5
years later they they went back and said
no no that was illegal clawed the money
back lots of players went bankrupt
because they couldn't pay it because
they'd offset it on off the tax and then
they wanted the interest back so i' I've
had to pay it was only 450 Grand I
shouldn't say only but it was only
because I wasn't earning the money at
the time because these were financial
advisors you know look I'm a weing class
kid I'm not a banker or a financial you
know wizard we were given Financial
advice from people who are regular to do
a trust at my bank is the queen was the
Queen's Bank passed away and hmrc so
they were telling us this is what you
should do with your money this the
advice and then
afterwards they changed they changed the
law and then went back when it was legal
and said no no we're going to so it's
almost like you can smoke it's legal to
smoke so for five years you're smoking
and then they say right smoking's
illegal and now we're gonna if you've
smoked you need to and and we're
actually going to charge your interest
for those siggies you had which is just
bizarre so lots of EX players so there
was a if you seen there's been a tsunami
of players who I grew up idolizing who
were you know household names all
bankrupt one of the guys pH me and it
was a short list I think of 3155 of them
that had all banded together because
they were like this is outrageous we've
been told this was legal anyway sorry to
digress but one of the things I would
change would would be we need to sort
out that the people who profit here and
make a lot of money in this country play
pay the proportionate amount of tax not
because they've got the best accountants
and they can afford billions to get away
with it um I think if we do that I think
that would be a step in in the right
direction amongst other things perfect
well head on over to locals where we ask
Joey your questions and a few more of
our
own I told Gad 10 years ago when he was
giving it to me tight on Match day and I
said to him look if you want all my all
my skeletons are out they all mine were
on CCTV and I've been to jail for them
they're out you know they've been on the
back of the pages all yours are still
hi I know stuff that he doesn't want
people to
[Music]
know